Kylie from Avatar The Last Airbender is
an air Nomad and that's not as crazy as
you might think first she doesn't look
anything like the other people from the
Fire Nation when you look at Zuko my
Zula ozai all of them have yellowish
eyes black hair and sharp features but
tylie gray eyes brown hair brown face
funny when you think about it because
she looks a lot like egg when you swap
their faces they basically look the same
this also lines up with how tiley fights
she's super floaty she likes to block
Chi and disarm opponents without killing
them this is exactly how the air Nomads
tried to fight they're defensive they
fly around they cause as little harm as
possible some air Nomad temples were
close to the Fire Nation so visiting
Airbenders isn't out of the realm of
possibility in the comics we see that
some Airbenders escaped Into the Fire
Nation before they got hunted down and
we know that Ty Lee traveled around in a
circus as well as had six other sisters
but we know nothing of her parents or
the fate of her family so maybe she was
hiding in that circus all along because